e oggi siamo team solette challenge
slime live non premere il pulsante
sbagliato abbiamo quattro pulsanti che
sono magici questi pulsanti perché
parlano quando sembravamo no perché se
lo sappiamo già che questa di ogni
giorno andiamo bendati a premere un
pulsante e sentiremo cosa ci dice di
mettere nel nostro slancio matura spende
per fare a meno di enti non sono molto
belli e ogni turno cambieranno caduta e
vincere questa sfida la vincerò io certo
che l'ha visto io sono sempre fortunato
vedremo alla fine del video come sempre
mentre nessun bacio con voi dovrete
votare servito iot in cellette evitare
di mostarda c'è giallo oppure fitto
parlerò che stavi che donna pur solito
potete votare il bandolo bellezza dello
slang quindi assicuratevi di guardare il
video fino alla fine uno bianca di sesso
maurizio io allora voglio mettere la
benda attimo si ribella io andai io per
me la metto il fronte costerà 90 calda
tanta mischiando si vedono i conoscenti
silenzio sbagliati perché si deve
sentire cosa dice il pulsante il
problema non vediamo sta così ma io so
già che proprio tale shopping nights
sfigato sapete la maionese
se sentite un gatto è un gatto che sta
fuori
però mi riconosco e ata randazzo e a cui
diamo da mangiare ogni tanto per questo
coso e poi alla finestra che vuole
entrare ma purtroppo berlino non ci va
molto d'accordo quindi purtroppo non
possiamo farlo entrare in casa noi ci
piacerebbe ma purtroppo usate
dove sono tutti qua
[Risate]
[Musica]
che fortuna
ingredienti che schifezza detto
all'inizio che lo portò dato vero è che
qui la maionese tra l'altro con la
bellissima con la trasparenza mentre ti
metterà puzzolente
almeno queste maionese di riso quindi
non dovrebbe puzzare diciamo vediamo tra
quasi un colorante con la bianca
praticamente la bianca mettete quello
trasparente ma io ma che sfortuna lo
scrivente public fortunatissimo mettiamo
allora sarà somma quali il mattino e che
essere adesso dovrà super flat detto che
dice allora lasciamo così così facciamo
seccare un po si è già adesso la giriamo
piano piano ci vuole un po di tempo
quindi vi racconta la storia della vita
dei minatori di bianchi che bra 8 e tuo
più brutto però anche prossimo quando di
sasso carta forno sasso
beh dai qualcosa di bello qualcosa di
bello anche se tuttora sempre di mario
rete vai fortunato vitali queste charlie
ecco qua il garante rosa almeno questo è
un bel ingrediente adoro questo colore
peccato che sarà rovinato dalla maionese
vediamo se riesce a coprire il color
maionese opaco che ballo è bellissimo
wow peccato solo che punto di maionese
ora quella digitale come di meta per il
comparto qualche ingrediente ci molla di
un giorno e mezzo a girarlo questo al
sistema di tagging evento di centa così
almeno esce a morbidoso superfly e
apparati rumori scoppiettanti o tra
super celesti che mi è diventato ben
loro zardi sia importante avviso
importante
[Applauso]
ho seguito e dei video precedenti sapete
che troppo consideravano nuovo super
etica e meno elastica non mi voglio
scuole vi dico che il 15 maggio sul
canale riuscirà a qualcosa riguardo alla
serie quindi scoprirete finalmente che
cos'è questa serie qualcosa che non
avreste trovato su youtube italia
matematica quindi non vedo la rassegna
tv la data 15 maggio ben tre reti lo
spoiler della serie a ora io sono sempre
io che te perché ci sarà il derby è
prodotta di mandare a casa qualcosa di
nuovo qualcosa di buono qualcosa di
buono
[Musica]
per cui avete capito
per fortuna io li odio però non so come
ci stanno la maionese
speriamo che ti capelli marcatori
negativo dei soggetti con belle colorate
nero marrone
no no scusate il vicario di lisbona che
gli ingredienti che vuoi tu come stai
rubando facciamo un po la challenger
rewind se non l'avete visto andate poi a
vederla in cui con il telecomando
mandavamo it di eboli potevamo non
mettere gli ingredienti quindi poi
andate a vederla perché super divertente
che è più che mai forse ci stanno bene
magari uscirà uno spray un po un po
canci che farà benissimo modo di sentire
quando cadranno tutte ma guarda ne metto
anche un altro fuoco con questo for
bello peccato che sa di maione perché
ma non sento la rete per che cosa
schiuma è una sorta di slutsky qui c'è
una grande fermano lenta con la cantina
ronchi carta con la luce sasso possibile
che userà mai dai ricchi non so che ho
fatto ma tocca proprio perché ti capiti
lo stesso ok vai acqua acqua se adesso
più breve l'acqua perché tante cene
schirru goletta alla grande
oppure l'acqua che i ora potete ammirare
ammirare come news live si rovinerà in
un secondo
[Applauso]
no ma perché così fortunate case gialle
vediamo ovviamente diventerà un credit
event e luca bacci di metà classifica
non c'è guerra ci sono i glitter che
risaltano almeno qui al mese un problema
di oggi è nerissimo lontani volte
neanche un po di no almeno i glitter
fanno un bell'effetto
la lettera firmata si sta ammorbidendo
tutta la schiuma da barba sicuro che ha
prodotto niente mr fantasy che vediamo
ora che la maledizione carta
qualcos'altro
non è forse ritratte il bottone
sbagliato ora sono causate dai e vai
[Risate]
rinfresco sì avete capito bene volo
meglio verde anche se ti soldi comunque
perché tra jazz e syrah un bellissimo
bird e acqua che non è capitato a lei
molto strano ora ovviamente ancora
capitato la fisc hai fatto viola è il
pulsante anche perde
l'altro col nero uscirà un bellissimo da
terra forse forse sì ma forse non si
vedrà un bel campo letto di niente è
morto un paio di concime così che usciva
un bellissimo verde smeraldo
meraviglioso fantastico giorno marino e
faccio a mettere il mio viola vediamo se
lo rovina o se lo migliora fa anche rima
penso che non si vedrà un fico secco
vediamo io non ci credo davvero il viola
riesce a sconfiggere il nero si che bono
ma non dimentichiamoci che puzza sempre
di che ai ragazzi siamo all'ultimo di un
roberto al turno decisivo perché
potrebbe rovinare lo schermo potrebbe
migliorarlo quindi vediamo un po come va
praticata famiglia stessa carta fuori
successo che sono le usata dai bendati
[Musica]
se non si fosse capito sei chiave
malissimo perchè si è sentito di rossi
ecco qua le mie paoli speriamo che
dimenticarci allora vediamo ora il
colorante sicuramente le cancellerà
tutte le colorerà tutte vediamo speriamo
che almeno faccia qualche zona mr
vediamo se ad ora ancora di maionese
ancora di maglia rete bambino in tutto
paparazzato merlino merlino proprio ad
aggiungere le palline solito fortunato
non hai avuto niente di male questo il
clamore visto che un clown e sono
infortunato allora le palline cubo che
secondo me verranno saranno super
colorate dalle diventeranno verdi però
almeno meter hanno ancora qualche suono
in più poiché non ci resta che attivare
il suo slam e vedere come migliore
attentamente siete pronti per fare il
bis line ma alla fine è uscito viola e
non nero per fortuna e viola un po
lucido vedete un po metallizzato e a
tutte le palline fishbowl infatti è un
po ruvido per ora ci fa sentire un po di
suoni
andai cannes trasformismo perché perché
non sprecare visible quindi si sono un
po di suoni crunchy fermento bandi
aspetto non è niente di che
vediamo ora quello digitale anche verde
perosa superato credo che abolire blu e
super morbido della famoso sentite che
può king pallina per elastico questa
volta lo attivato pure bene non vi sono
cadute le fishbowl sto migliorando
proprio tantissimo eccolo qua volta il
colore e soprattutto che si vedono le
palline le palline blu che non sono
stato assorbito con fermento dal colore
verde e che dilata risaltano molto bene
quindi è carina con metallizzata urlo
provicinale troppo il bio
bellissima sempre così che fare ma
votando i quali il sondaggio servisse
vitale o se vinco io volta bellezza soli
essere un bel mi piace se volete vedere
la seconda parte dobbiamo premere il
pulsante sbagliato magari avranno di
arrivi in città oppure no 4 cappellini e
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccando su quello che
preferite funzione ciao